the old market town of ghoul in the east
riding of yorkshire
home to britain's most inland port
once at the heart of britain's coal
export drive
like many northern towns ghoul has
suffered from a steady
post-industrial decline
[Applause]
but now at last there are signs of a
revival
this morning we're going to do a math
test
the 90 odd peoples here are a mix of
those from families who have lived in
ghoul for generations
and newer arrivals attracted by a
renewed sense of optimism in the area we
have families that come to this school
from all different backgrounds we are
very sort of
successful
business-minded families and we have
families that come from
areas where work is difficult to get and
perhaps um income streams have been hard
and choices have not been great for them
and just watching them this morning to
be honest you wouldn't be able to tell
which is which you can't tell which is
which because they're they've got a
lovely vibrant personalities and we try
and instill through our school
high aspirations and hope and
the fact that you know the world is an
oyster really
and it isn't just the head teacher who's
confident about the direction of travel
you all grow up
what do you want to do do you want to
stay living here in ghoul or
would you move away there's two things
which i'd like to be i don't and i
can't make my mind a pitch either a
teacher or a trained driver why train
driver because i've loved trains ever
since i was born and
actually it's just my favorite thing
and just a few miles away along the
humber they're building the platform for
ghouls future prosperity
the german transport company siemens is
developing this site into a 200 million
pound manufacturing facility
they have orders to build the next
generation of rolling stock for
customers including the london
underground and the company is dug in
for the long haul
we are a business to community being in
the community working in the community
taking the knowledge we have imparting
that into the community inspiring people
giving giving people a pride in a sense
of place i think that's been lacking in
many places giving people that they're
from some place they should be proud of
that place to know the heritage of the
place but actually also to think what's
important what's achievable to change
the narrative around places like this
that's why this is so cool we we have a
customer in london tfl who's buying
trains for us that'll be manufactured
here in ghoul
by a company that is in the community
supporting the community
while everyone welcomes what siemens is
doing here in ghoul there are those who
think that it should not just be left to
private enterprise to drive the north's
industrial regeneration
government 2 has a role to play
but there are calls for that political
power not to be hoarded in whitehall but
devolved to regions like this
there's a lot of cash that's going to go
into levelling up
it's not just the amount of money but
it's how it's spent
who decides
the challenge here has to be that
whitehall can't decide
whitehall can do many things well and it
can probably deal with the big
businesses like siemens but when it
comes to those more detailed discussions
a civil servant in whitehall can never
be across the detail of what's going to
bring local smes
for instance to the buildings behind me
which are going to be the clustering of
businesses around this particular
factory and that does require local
leaders to be more empowered and it
requires industrialists to have people
there who they can deal with
you are too bright
whatever the government's plans and
future timetables for delivery there is
no doubting the impact one company is
having here who can tell me about
siemens
it's a factory that makes trains and
vehicles like this
they
work really hard to
make these trains and make different
types of vehicles
and they're really
really hard
siemens promotion of a primary
engineering program to help get these
kids trained up in the necessary skills
for jobs at the factory is already
proving to be a big hit
if big companies like siemens keep
investing in places like google then i'm
really optimistic because they give
opportunity they give opportunities for
um young people
to invest in their own area if they want
to because there's the structures there
to do that and they can work at any
level it can be a brit they can do top
level work within their own community
but they can also
aspire to work internationally or go all
over the world or have you know
big ambitious
um
ideas about being successful
it's almost impossible not to be
uplifted by the optimism that we found
here it's not just the jobs or the new
infrastructure it is the sense that this
town
has found a purpose again
and that it will have status and respect
and
even a bit of love
but to make leveling up work this is
going to have to happen in hundreds of
places across the country
and if it doesn't
boris johnson and his government are
going to pay a pretty high political
price
it's high stakes for the prime minister
as well
because this has been what he'll be
remembered by
does he make leveling up a reality he
wants it to be a reality but can he push
it through government can he push it
through treasury and there's real
question marks there and a government
that can't deliver more successful towns
is a government that will have a lot of
questions to answer at the next general
election boris johnson has already
marked his place in history as the prime
minister who succeeded in his promise to
deliver brexit
a new government white paper on
levelling up is due this side of
christmas the prime minister wants to be
remembered for keeping his promise to
those who gifted him with a landslide
if he doesn't the season of goodwill
he's enjoyed so far in towns like ghoul
could rapidly freeze into a winter of
discontent